الأمر لا يتعلق بجود بيلينجهام الآن
بدون إجابتي الآن بالتأكيد لا ولكن
كان الأمر جيدًا دائمًا ولم
أفهم أبدًا، لذلك أنا
لماذا
نتحدث باستمرار عن أشياء
لا يمكننا الحصول عليها نظريًا لذلك لا يمكن أن
يكون لدينا ستة لاعبين في الصيف مقابل
100 مليون للجميع على سبيل المثال
سيقول الجميع ذلك حسنًا، هذا أمر
واضح نوعًا ما، وهذا هو الشيء الذي
يجب عليك أن
تدرك ما يمكنك فعله ومن ثم عليك
العمل به، فما مقدار الأموال
المتوفرة لدينا ثم عليك
العمل به وهذا  هذه هي
الوظيفة التي عليك القيام بها، ولا يتعلق الأمر بأننا
لسنا أطفالًا،
أعني أنني أسأل طفلة تبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات
في عيد الميلاد ماذا تريد في
عيد الميلاد وأقول لك أنني أريد أن أحصل على
سيارة فيراري لا أعرفها.  لن تقول
أوه، هذه فكرة جيدة، قد تقول لا، لا،
إنها باهظة الثمن ولا يمكنك قيادتها بأي شكل من الأشكال